keine frage die anti baby pille ist
bisher reine frauensache doch das soll
sich ändern und so forschen fachleute
schon seit jahren an der pille für den
mann ein forschungsteam aus den usa
meldet jetzt einen durchbruch die
experten und expertinnen haben ein
mittel vorgestellt das die produktion
der spermien vorübergehend stoppt und
nur wenige nebenwirkungen mit sich
bringen soll kommt dieses mittel also
tatsächlich als sicheres
verhütungsmittel in frage und wann
können wir es nutzen klick zum science
fiction
hier gibt es täglich faszinierendes
seines videos abonniert den kanal nur
dann verpasst er nichts herzlich
willkommen eine wirkliche alternative
zum kondom haben wir männer nicht und
ein sicheres und wirksames
verhütungsmittel für den mann zu finden
ist alles andere als einfach
forschungsteams weltweit forschen schon
seit jahren mit hochdruck daran
sie verfolgen viele verschiedene ansätze
die von spermien schädigen gels bis hin
zum samenleiter ventil reichen aber
natürlich wäre auch eine andere sichere
und wirksame hormon methode
wünschenswert und zwar im besten fall
eine wie keine oder nur sehr wenige
nebenwirkungen mit sich bringt doch um
eine hormonelle verhütung für den mann
zu entwickeln muss eine riesige
herausforderung bewältigt werden und
zwar lässt sich der männliche körper in
dieser hinsicht nicht so einfach
austricksen wie es beim weiblichen
körper der fall ist denn die
antibabypille täuscht diesem jahr vor
dem weiblichen körper schwanger zu sein
so kann der eisprung gestoppt werden und
zwar mit einer relativ niedrigen
hormondosis bei männern dagegen gibt es
keine natürliche phase in der er
unfruchtbar ist das bedeutet dass hohe
mengen an hormonen notwendig sind um die
bildung von samenzellen zuverlässig zu
verhindern und so zeigte sich bei den
bisherigen wirkstoffen die für die
hormonelle männliche empfängnisverhütung
entwickelt worden waren
viele unerwünschte nebenwirkungen so
lautet das erklärte ziel das
effizienteste mittel mit den geringsten
nebenwirkungen zu finden im klartext der
wirkstoff muss die sperma produktion
stoppen darf dabei aber keinesfalls die
männliche libido also die lust haben das
hätte ja dann auch nicht so viel sinn
die ergebnisse eines forschungsteams
geben jetzt neue hoffnung der wirkstoff
achtung namens elfmeter methyl 19 nord
testosteron dodik kühl
karbonat oder abgekürzt elfmeter mmtc
einfacher soll die körpereigene
produktion von testosteron in den hoden
stoppen
dabei handelt es sich um das wichtigste
männliche sexualhormon so wird dann
letztendlich auch die produktion von
spermien gestoppt dazu christina lang
die an der studie beteiligt war
unsere ergebnisse zeigen dass diese
pille die spermienproduktion reduziert
aber die libido aufrecht hält 40 gesunde
männer zwischen 18 und 50 jahren hatten
an der studie teilgenommen
30 von ihnen hatten tatsächlich die neu
entwickelte pille für den mann
eingenommen die anderen zehn teilnehmer
dagegen erhielten ein placebo also ein
wirkungsloses medikament der test lief
28 tage lang und das ergebnis ist
tatsächlich vielversprechend denn auch
wenn einige männer unter gewichtszunahme
und leichten kopfschmerzen klagten wirkt
die pille leichte nebenwirkungen wie
müdigkeit oder akne gab es nur bei
wenigen männern doch der test zeigte
auch dass einige tester an
potenzproblemen litten zwei männer
litten unter einer leichten erektilen
dysfunktion also einer erektionsstörung
fünf teilnehmer gaben an dass ihr
sexualtrieb durch die pille leicht
abgenommen hatte
dennoch ist das forschungsteam
optimistisch bald einen durchbruch zu
erzielen
schon in zehn jahren könnte demnach ein
hormonelles mittel zur
empfängnisverhütung für männer auf den
markt kommt dazu stefanie page von der
university of washington in seattle
wir arbeiten parallel an zwei oralen
verhütungsmitteln um das feld der
vergütungs medizin voranzubringen und
den besten wirkstoff zu finden
fest steht dass das neu entwickelte
mittel vor einer möglichen
marktzulassung noch viele langweilige
prozesse durchlaufen muss das ist bei
der zulassung von medikamenten für
üblich so wurde das mittel bisher
lediglich in einer so genannten face
wann studie getestet bei der nur wenige
probanden teilnehmer erst danach folgen
umfangreiche tests diese face to face sc
studien laufen dann aber meistens über
viele jahre erst wenn diese studien
erfolgreich sind darf das präparat
zugelassen werden und so lässt die
alternative zum kondom
erst einmal noch auf sich warten und
noch bei einem anderen thema spielt die
chemie in unserem körper eine große
rolle
neue epidemie einsamkeit das macht sie
mit unserem körper
draufklicken anschauen und natürlich
klicks um science-fiction abonnieren
wenn es auch nicht gemacht habt bis dann
bleibt dran